Speaker 1: Let's go next to Nick from St.
Louis, Missouri. You're on the air. Hi, David,
Speaker 3: my question for you is so with the 2022
midterms coming up, I just would think it'd be a
no brainer for Biden to take some sort of stance
on decriminalizing marijuana. And if unlike the
federal level. Yeah, I just think that'd be
an easy layup for Democrats to, you know,
make a comeback since the like, everyone's saying
that they're going to get slaughtered in the 2022
midterms. So what's your opinion on that?
Speaker 1: I completely agree. This sort
of came up a little bit on the show last last
week. I think that it would be an easy, obvious
net positive for Biden to push decriminalization.
There are a couple of different perspectives on
how it could be done. Could it be done by
executive order? Could it be done by simply
directing the DEA to sort of make it happen? There
are some who say he can't do it, although I've
not found those legal arguments compelling as a
layperson. But yeah, I completely agree. There are
people who would be mad at Biden decriminalizing
cannabis, but it would be an obvious net positive,
and I think he has very little interest
in actually trying to make it happen.
Speaker 3: Do you think his reluctance to not
try to make anything happen on that front is
because of his own personal or religious beliefs?
Speaker 1: No, I don't think so. I mean, it's sort
of like with the student loan thing, right, where
people are saying, why isn't he forgiving student
loan debt? Like, I never thought he cared about
student loan debt. And I think at one point,
he said he would do 10 grand. And people were
saying 50. At no point did I believe he really
cared about it. I don't think it's religious.
I don't think it's personal. I think there's
just certain issues he doesn't care about. And he
sort of talked about them because he was running a
campaign and people impose these issues on him. I
just don't think he cares. I wish I had something
deeper, but I think it's it's that simple.
Speaker 3: But I mean, going to student loans,
but given that his wife is a teacher. Yeah, you
would think that they would have some sort of
impact and you know, the priorities.
I agree, especially because it's so
popular those two issues on on the left.
Marijuana, maybe more. You know, everyone. But
I just I don't see why. No action
or no even updates, even avoiding
questions and briefings about those issues.
Speaker 1: I agree with you 100 percent. And you
know, there's two sides on this one is he's just
being advised incorrectly. The other one would be,
there are downsides you and I aren't thinking
of, and that's why he's staying away from these
issues. It's probably a mix of both.
Speaker 3:
OK, well, thanks for answering my question, David.
Speaker 1: All right. My pleasure. Great to hear
from you. Why don't we go next to really
people from all over the world today? It's
quite a quite a situation. Let's try attack from
Denmark. Attack, you were on the air. And for
whatever reason, I'm unable to unmute attack and
I don't know why. That's really weird. I should
have all of the necessary permissions, but I am
unable. I apologize. Attack. If a moderator can
look into why I am unable to unmute attack from
Denmark, I would love to go back to attack. Very,
very strange. Wow. Let's try. Let's try Greg from
Detroit. Wow. Now I can't. I actually can't unmute
anyone right now. That is really weird. Let me
see if I can. Let's see if I can reconnect. Is
our system failing? Let's try going back to
attack from Denmark. Ah, there we go. Attack
from Denmark. You are now on the air. What's on
your mind? Yeah. Hello, can you hear me? I can.
Speaker 4: All right. Yeah, so I had
a question basically around the photo
seems to me that a lot of American media.
Speaker 1: A lot of American media see so,
so attack was just muted again. I think we're
having some kind of permission issue, guys. So if
moderators can look into this, one of two things
is happening. Either someone is accidentally doing
something with the server muting or someone has
gotten a permission they they shouldn't have.